est-ce qu'il existe toujours pour vous
il y en aura toujours oui mais c'est
pire qu'avant donc bon parce que dans sa
vie ça avait bien avancé vous aviez fait
avancer les choses à un moment là vous
pensez qu'on a reculé non ça c'est assez
avec le temps et
aujourd'hui est-ce que quand vous
définiriez le mouvement des gilets
jaunes Maxime et vous je veux dire on
est quand même 4 ans après on est
toujours en train de poser la question
si on est toujours là c'est ça
je pense que dans le public là il y a
plein de gens qui savent pas payer leurs
factures ou qui se galère à se poser la
question de savoir si ils vont pouvoir
le faire je pense que quand on voit les
blindés de la gendarmerie qui viennent
d'être livrés on s'attend pas à recevoir
des fleurs et de se faire recevoir pour
essayer de se faire comprendre je pense
que
la situation
ils sont plus aussi visibles qu'avant
mais gilets jaunes en fait pour vous ce
que vous êtes en train de dire c'est que
les gilets jaunes c'est c'est les
citoyens qui souffrent c'est ça mon
expliquer dès le départ que le fait
d'avoir un gilet sur le dos ça voulait
rien dire il y avait toutes les classes
socio-professionnelles qui étaient dans
la rue il y avait des juges des avocats
des policiers des pompiers
tout le monde en fait qui qui dénonçait
la même chose et on est passé on est sur
une émission de divertissement ici
magazine divertissement on fait le tout
hein parce que divertir ça veut dire
détourner l'attention et c'est ce qui a
été fait pendant quatre ans détourner
l'attention des gens qui pouvaient se
poser la question de savoir ce qu'on
faisait dans la rue
alors que c'était plutôt très clair
je sais pas vous regardez le traitement
médiatique de ce qui a été fait pendant
quatre ans vous êtes en tout cas la
plupart des médias se sont attaqués à
Eric Drouet moi Jérôme Rodriguez en
essayant d'aller chercher si on était
d'extrême droite d'extrême gauche
antisémite raciste homophobe sexy des
antécédents au collège ou si on a envie
de tout ça a été fait pour tuer le
mouvement et pour réussir pour essayer
de toute façon les amandes les
arrestations les condamnations moi je
trouve que c'est intéressant ce que vous
dites là tous les deux vous pensez à
quel média la vérité tous sans exception
tous même ici quand on est arrivé ici
aussi on est ouais
non on a on a plutôt défendu les gilets
jaunes
à venir
la parole avoir regretter maintenant ah
j'ai jamais dit que je regrette non ce
soir au contraire non il y a eu un petit
accroc
la manière dont je le fais par contre ce
que j'ai du mal à comprendre c'est qu'on
puisse dire qu'on nous a donné la parole
quand tout ce qu'on disait pouvait être
retenu contre nous c'était presque un
jugement
et la moindre le moindre dérapage parce
qu'effectivement moi quand je suis
arrivé ou Eric quand on est arrivé sur
des plateaux de télévision on est ni
politologue ni sociologue ni
géopoliticien ni mathématicien de la
télé et la moindre petite erreur a été
utilisée pour discréditer un mouvement
entier de gens qui luttaient et qui s'en
prenaient plein la gueule dans les rues
pendant quatre ans et qui continue
toujours je veux dire qu'est-ce que ça a
donné ça ça donnait des gens qui se sont
fait mutiler ça a donné des gens qui ont
été emprisonnés une mutilation c'est pas
un débat sur un plateau de télé c'est
une main arrachée c'est un oeil en moins
il y a des gens qui sont morts aussi
dans le mouvement il y en a 11 qui sont
décédés on parle de vie enlever là on
parle pas non plus de débat sur un
plateau de télé ou de paroles de temps
de parole
je vous sens tous les deux je vous sens
je sens triste je me sens je sais pas un
peu des abusé et vous dites quatre ans
après il y a rien à bouger
tu es déçu quand on voit ce qui se passe
maintenant moi j'ai des gens j'ai un
garage et des gens qui passent au garage
on me dit c'est encore pire qu'avant
vous êtes sortis pour 1,40 le litre et
on est à plus d'euros
vraiment c'est c'est pire en pire
Eric ce serait quoi la solution alors
aujourd'hui
Eric et Maxime c'est quoi quatre ans
après
vous êtes prêt tous parce que vous êtes
presque qui va se passer là
dites-moi alors je sais pas vous avez
pas l'impression que ça les renfiler les
gants quoi je sais pas c'est bien
possible parce que vous étiez pas loin
de gagner
la méthode de discussion sur des
plateaux de télé il y a eu des méthodes
de tentative d'essayer de mettre des
revendications en avant il y a eu des
tentatives du gouvernement de venir
discuter avec nous hein parce que on a
été invité à ma camion vous avez vu qui
un a refusé d'y aller parce que on
voulait que ce soit transparent et on a
j'ai encore les textos sur mon téléphone
si vous voulez on nous a refusé de la
transmission en direct il fallait qu'on
soit dans un bureau tranquille
je crois que c'est à cause de ça
d'ailleurs
tout ça moi j'avais fait un live quand
même avec le téléphone mais
d'accord aujourd'hui donc Maxime tu vas
nous dire tu vas dire vous imaginez bien
ce qui s'est passé pour revenir à ce que
tu disais tout à l'heure toi tu vas nous
dire c'est vrai que nous et ce qu'on a
ici nous les gilets jaunes on a toujours
dit c'est les Français qui souffrent on
en a reçu plein ici et on le sait il
souffre toujours autant c'est des mecs
et des Français qui arrivent pas le
disent du mois qui se disent je vais
manger quoi le 11 mais c'est pas
forcément les Français en fait au bout
de quatre ans j'ai fait des conférences
partout en Europe pour expliquer ce qui
se passait en France en parlant de la
violence policière la violence estatique
par exemple en Grèce c'est la même chose
au Portugal c'est la même chose mais là
pour le mouvement a été lancé ça a été
suivi dans 47 pays du monde c'est pas
français c'est systémique en tout cas
nous on parle de la France parce que
voilà ici
c'est quoi le problème pour vous
c'est que vous avez un système qui est
en train de d'arriver au bout parce que
la planche à billets ne marche plus
parce que les ressources elles sont pas
infinies parce que il y a des grandes
puissances qui vont se faire la guerre
bientôt et qui commencent déjà se la
faire pour des puissants pour des
ressources qui vont commencer à manquer
pour faire rouler leur Ferrari ou voler
leurs Airbus ou je sais pas encore quel
connerie et pendant ce temps-là on tape
sur la gueule des gens
qui veulent juste vivre pas survivre
vivre donc on va aller dire je sais pas
respirer bien respirer d'un poumon
mettez le chauffage à 19 degrés arrêtez
de vous plaindre et dans le même temps
ceux qui vous dit ça font un G20 en
allant tous là-bas en jet privé et en
consommant je sais pas combien de
milliers de litres de kérosène juste
Eric et Maxime est-ce que ça vous a
porté préjudice d'être les leaders de ce
mouvement aujourd'hui mais c'est ça
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé on a toujours
dit qu'il y avait pas de leader et je
vois les leaders du mouvement d'accord
je sais pas qui a fait le titre mais il
va falloir qu'il prenne les cours ça
fait 4 ans qu'on lui dit que c'est pas
le cas mais bon alors des gilets jaunes
on est des personnes qui ont été
médiates médiatiquement appliqués sans
le demander en plus parce que moi j'ai
jamais demandé à venir sur un plateau de
télé c'est toi qui m'invite bien sûr la
première fois mais j'ai bien fait j'ai
bien fait de t'inviter et c'est pas une
question je sais pas si tu as bien fait
parce que ma vie après c'était pas tout
rose mais alors
maman il fallait bien aussi parler du
mouvement est-ce que c'est c'est une
méthode de fonctionnement que que vous
avez tous dans la tête il faut qui ait
des représentants pour dire quoi pour
dire quelque chose que l'autre va
contredire que l'autre va contredire je
m'attendais d'ailleurs à voir sur le
plateau d'autres personnes qui étaient
impliquées médiatiquement peut-être pour
essayer de faire du scandale alors que
je leur veux pas chacun a fait comme il
voulait le kitch a défendu ses opinions
comme il le souhaitait
eric a fait d'une certaine manière j'ai
fait d'une certaine manière Priscilla a
fait une certaine manière et on continue
tous d'une certaine manière mais là on
parle de la vie des gens enfin je sais
pas il y a 11 millions de personnes dans
ce pays qui vivent de seuil de pauvreté
mais c'est pour ça qu'on vous a suicide
les suicides explosent partout dans
toutes les branches sociales catastrophe
c'est Maxime c'est on est encore là à se
poser des questions pour ça c'est pour
ça que vous en pensez de ça qu'on vous
invite extrêmement peur l'électricité
l'essence le gaz tout là à partir de
janvier ça va être ça fait tellement
peur que les pays s'y préparent Emmanuel
Macron il a commandé 67 millions de
munitions de fusil d'assaut et 90
blindés qui sont en train d'être livrés
là les mêmes qui sont utilisés en
république Centrafrique contre les
émeutes alors je sais pas si Maxime donc
Maxime c'est des fleurs maximum juste
quand vous disiez tout à l'heure vous
voyez bien ce qui va se passer il va se
passer quoi
bah je sais pas vous avez un ancien
préféré l'Allemand qui dit que on est à
deux doigts de tirer à balle réelle sur
les gens dans la rue
vous avez les renseignements
territoriaux qui font des notes de
service en disant que ils sont en train
de boire une colère populaire légitime
montée et que ça risque de faire des
débordements massifs vous avez des
unités de gendarmerie de police
nationale qui sont formés à gérer des
notes vous avez des pays comme
l'Allemagne qui met ça en place aussi
l'Espagne l'Italie le Portugal donc vous
avez fait peur vous avez fait très très
peur à nos gouvernements ils ont eu peur
de la commune on leur a rappelé la
commune s'il te plaît juste qu'on laisse
parler Maxime et Eric donc vous dites
quoi c'est il va se passer quoi 100
jours en janvier vous pensez que ça va
j'ai pas de bouche je suis pas Madame
Irma tout ce que je dis c'est que on est
assis sur des institutions
qu'on vante comme étant génial ou
surtout les murs de nos bâtiments comme
l'Arc de Triomphe que je vois derrière
là il y a des résistants qui luttent
pour délivrer un pays d'une oppression
d'une classe sociale qui les méprisent
et quand on voit ça là et qu'on entend
la violence était dans la rue la
violence elle est pas dans la rue en
général quand les gens vont dans la rue
en lançant des pavés c'est qu'ils c'est
qu'ils ont plus rien à les autres la
violence elle est pas dans la rue quand
il y a pas de violence dans les maisons
en fait et la violence elle est de plus
en plus forte dans les maisons elle est
enfin je sais pas si bah
c'est là où on a été écouté au final
tous les jours ça s'est passé
pacifiquement c'est là où il y a il y a
pas eu discussion il y a rien eu c'est
grave de dire ça ça veut dire que très
regrettable que ça se passe comme ça
mais si on a fallu de la violence pour
qu'il y ait quelque chose qui se
débloque un petit peu
pour que ça bouge c'est ce que vous avez
vu quoi parce que ça habite et tu
trouves ça violent de voir des gens dans
ces des pavés ce que je peux comprendre
mets-toi dans l'autre sens et essaye de
comprendre ce que c'est à quel point ça
peut être violent de te dire ton fils
est mort parce que il y avait pas
d'ambulance pour aller chercher ta
grand-mère est morte parce que les pas
de bah il y a pas assez de personnel tu
vois c'est c'est hyper violent ça dans
la vie des gens bien sûr et quand ça
arrive il y a personne pour écouter ces
gens-là
juste anti-système et anti-macron mais
anti-système
de l'armée de terre française qui a
défendu le pays aussi
d'extrême droite et que je défends
l'extrême droite c'est pas vraiment vrai
donc vous fiez pas Wikipédia c'est pas
du vrai journaliste un petit peu quand
même votre parcours mais malgré tout en
fait c'est quoi en fait votre projet
parce que vous voulez pas être récupéré
ni par LSI ni par le RN je crois que
vous aviez été approché au moment des
élections
on m'a même proposé de l'argent depuis
que j'aille dans les rues ah oui la
politique pour en faire quoi parce
qu'aujourd'hui quand même il y a 13
parties en France qui sont présentés aux
élections présidentielles
la politique c'est la gestion de la cité
on veut participer à la gestion de la
cité puisqu'on a même revendiqué c'était
une de nos revendications principales le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne en
toute matière révocatoire argatoire
législatif et constitutionnel
ça n'a pas été écouté Maxime j'avais dit
un truc important il y a un instant vous
aviez il y a deux partis politiques qui
ont essayé de de vous approcher et quoi
vous ayez vous ont même proposé de
l'argent pourquoi pour pour éviter qu'on
a qu'on continue à sortir dans la rue
parce que ça fait chier parce que vous
comprenez des gars qui commencent à
gueuler et puis qui en plus continuent à
gueuler pendant plus d'une semaine je
vous rappelle que le premier weekend
Emmanuel Macron a dit c'est des gens qui
ont besoin de travailler lundi ils
seront plus dans les rues bon il y a pas
de bol et sur ce coup-là il s'est loupé
alors à l'arrivée vous n'avez juste
personne du gouvernement vous avez
refusé vous n'avez vu personne personne
non moi j'ai eu j'ai parlé dans les
manifestations à des politiques j'ai
réussi à faire dire des députés de la
France insoumise par exemple qu'il
savait très bien qu'ils avaient aucun
pouvoir et qui changerait rien quand je
suis arrivé la première fois à la télé
on va faire passer pour un con puis
après par exemple j'ai creusé un truc
qui s'appelle la Constitution française
c'est les règles du jeu l'échiquier sur
lequel on est tous
on me demande de faire confiance à des
politiques comme par exemple on a un
article 27 qui est génial qui dit tout
le mandat impératif est nul vous avez
tous un emploi quasiment je sais pas en
tout cas si vous avez un emploi vous
avez un contrat de travail sur ce
contrat de travail tout est déterminé
surtout ce que vous avez à faire et si
vous le faites pas il y a des sanctions
et vous êtes viré parce que c'est normal
que si vous fassiez pas votre boulot on
vous dégage le seul contrat en France il
y a pas cette obligation c'est le
contrat politique et c'est inscrit dans
notre Constitution il y a des élections
les élections l'intérêt l'article 3 le
peuple est souverain par le biais de ses
représentants et par la voie
référendaire quand vous avez des
représentants qui parlent à votre place
et qui sont soumis à aucune obligation à
quel moment vous pouvez leur faire
confiance mais alors des élections à
chaque fois s'il vous plaît donc c'est
un peu le sous syndrome de Stockholm
celui qui crée le problème il va nous
trouver la solution
de le trouver il y a Jérôme et à Jérôme
rodriez qui m'appelle
c'est vrai qu'il était une autre un
autre gilet jaune tiens alors qu'est-ce
qu'il veut nous dire qui lui a payé très
cher il a un œil exactement voilà Jérôme
Rodriguez que vous avez des nouvelles
des autres vous parce que c'est aussi un
mouvement vous avez gardé des contacts
avec des gens que vous avez pu connaître
ça crée beaucoup de biens
je sais pas comment vous expliquer
comment
comment ça ça fait quand vous vous
rappelez certains moments de ce qu'on a
pu vivre dans les rues Jérôme bonsoir
Jérôme tu m'as appelé mon Jérôme
qu'est-ce que tu voulais nous dire tu
nous regardes sûrement on est en direct
je l'ai pas vu bonsoir à toi merci de me
répondre on va juste faire dans le
concret on va juste faire dans le
concret ça va prendre une minute légumes
secs plus 14 % légumes plus 15 % légumes
frais puissent 34 % les œufs 15 % le
beurre et la crème fraîche 17 % le
papier toilette 18 % l'huile de
tournesol 20% les pâtes 21 % la viande
surgelée 29% la viande de poulet 100% 2
euros le litre de gasoil les factures
d'énergie qui explosent voilà c'est quoi
aujourd'hui un gilet jaune quelqu'un qui
ne peut pas joindre les deux bouts
encore plus qu'hier
est-ce que ça c'est du concret parce que
je pense que c'est tout à fait
à la maison la colère est toujours
présente faut juste qu'à un moment donné
le plateau comprenne on s'est fait crevé
des cieux c'est à dire que pour des
délits d'opinion parce qu'il y a une
célèbre pub sur une autre chaîne qui dit
pour délit d'opinion parce que
aujourd'hui dans une démocratie qui
s'appelle la France on s'est fait crever
des yeux parce qu'on a juste dit on en a
marre de raquer et de pas pouvoir
entendre les deux groupes voilà j'en ai
pris juste une minute
envoie la police pour apporter des
réponses militaires merci des armes de
guerre merci Jérôme merci Jérôme merci
Jérôme merci Jérôme je t'embrasse voilà
je voulais intervenir Gilles mais quand
on regarde une carte de France on voit
qu'à Tarbes et encore le mouvement à
Montauban et encore des gilets jaunes je
voyais ça et là on a l'impression que
vous et je comprends tout à fait au nom
de la répression vous avez souffert dans
votre cher je comprends Jérôme aussi on
a l'impression que du coup vous ne
voulez pas rallumer le mouvement alors
que le constat c'est que tout explose ma
question elle est simple c'est est-ce
qu'en janvier là quand les factures
effectivement d'électricité vont arriver
et ce qu'en janvier vous pensez que le
mouvement des gilets jaunes va repartir
et est-ce que vous allez vous impulser
alors focaliser sur les gilets jaunes de
façon ça va être les gens en général
parce que là c'est plus du tout possible
ce qui a fait que il y avait pas assez
de gens dans les c'est justement parce
que on a stigmatisé les gilets jaunes en
disant si vous sortez vous allez sortir
avec des casseurs dans la rue des
antisémites des fachos des racistes et
j'en passe la liste elle est il manquait
plus que violeur parce que mais bon la
liste elle est longue
moi je dis à toutes les personnes qui se
sentent concernées parce qu'il est en
train de se passer c'est à dire à peu
près
au minimum 11 millions de personnes
c'est quand même pas mal mais je pense
qu'il y en a beaucoup plus hein ce qu'il
y a une classe médiane qui est en train
de prendre cher
je leur dis arrêtez de vous poser la
question de savoir avec qui vous allez
sortir dans la rue si vous devez sortir
dans la rue arrêtez de vous poser la
question de savoir avec qui vous allez
lutter si c'est pour l'intérêt collectif
parce que justement le pouvoir
médiatique a joué sur les divisions
d'opinions pour que et divertissement
pour que les gens se posent pas les
bonnes questions
j'étais quand j'étais passé ici j'avais
dit une phrase c'était
si vous devez vous poser une seule
question c'est quelle est ma place
là-dedans imaginez-vous dans une
fourmilière c'est pas participer un
système si le si du jour au lendemain la
fourmilière elle doit se casser la
gueule le système va faire tout pour ce
sauver le cul mais vous en tant que
fourmi quel est votre place là-dedans et
je vous regarde tous ici derrière la
caméra tous ceux qui sont sur plateau on
a plus ou moins des vies différentes
même grandement des vies différentes on
a tous des moyens financiers différents
mais demain si ça explose je pense pas
que c'est un billet de banque ou une
carte bleue qui va vous sauver je pense
pas que c'est une position dans la
société non plus qui va vous sauver et
et pourtant dans les lives histoire
c'est facile de voir que ça s'est déjà
produit c'est facile de voir ce que ça
peut produire et c'est facile de voir
jusqu'où ça peut aller
on y va tranquillement sûrement et puis
on est encore en train de se dire je
sais pas comme si vous aviez un 44
tonnes sur l'autoroute on va taper un
mur tout le monde le dit tous les
experts de la planète les politiciens
les géopoliticiens les collapsologues
tout le monde vous dit on est à deux
doigts on est à H13 dans l'effondrement
systémique et on est tous en train de se
battre pour la couleur des vitres pour
comment on met la ceinture est-ce que tu
es d'accord si je mets à nœud papillon
on en a rien à carrer de tout ça parce
que quand ça va taper que vous ayez une
carte bleue un costard ou que vous
l'aviez des chiottes vous allez prendre
tarif pareil en fait Maxime qu'est-ce
qu'il faudrait faire alors ce serait
quoi la solution je sais pas qui prend
les décisions dans ce pays
c'est le gouvernement qui vous dit à
chaque fois qu'il y a quelque chose qui
va pas mais là monsieur mes chers
compatriotes on gère
tout va bien se passer
[ __ ] ça a l'air de vachement marcher
leur système
tant qu'on sera encore dans sur un
échiquier où les règles c'est pas nous
qui les décidons tant qu'on sera dans un
système où les gens qui décident sont
protégés et se protègent par l'édiction
de loi de processus législatif et j'en
passe et les meilleurs et ben on sera là
en train de se poser des questions
mettez une assemblée il y a des députés
une assemblée vous savez ce que c'est le
49-3 oui d'accord mais le président a
été élu démocratiquement
démocratiquement combien de personnes
dans le pays
la démocratie c'est quand la totalité de
la population prend une décision
Emmanuel Macron a dit une phrase très
importante Camille quasiment un coup de
fusil à la démocratie il a dit je ne
serai pas le président du vote blanc
quand vous avez 70% du pays qui veut pas
voter pour un pour un pour un pour
quelqu'un qui se représente et que vous
dites j'ai été élu démocratiquement
j'ai du mal à comprendre et maintenant
on peut mettre la démocratie en avant
donc la démocratie
justement bien au contraire mais alors
c'est quoi votre projet
de la République il y a quoi comme ça se
passe concrètement
concrètement on comprend rien en fait
c'est quoi concrètement
je vais essayer de l'expliquer
différemment
aujourd'hui on a un système qui montre
qui marche pas on est d'accord ou pas et
où ça marche dans le monde en fait
alors il dit que c'est dans le monde un
Maxime j'ai jamais dit que c'était
français il a dit tout à l'heure et
est-ce que ce système il est typiquement
français ou est-ce que dans la plupart
des pays démocratiques c'est à peu près
équivalent le genre de système
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un Conseil d'État
enfin une représentation nationale une
Assemblée nationale et tout et tout un
système hiérarchique qui fait que
théoriquement on est censé être écouté
on peut voter on peut donner son avis
c'est la démocratie c'est la démocratie
sauf que
le système il bloque parce que on peut
donner son avis mais pas tout le monde
pas ceux qui sont pas d'accord
70% n'est pas d'accord on les écoute pas
par exemple déjà la démocratie là il en
prend un sacré coup dans la gueule et
puis admettons les écoute pas
donc il y a de minorité de gens qui vont
voter pour un Président il est élu
démocratiquement et puis il arrive au
pouvoir et on n'est pas d'accord et
l'Assemblée nationale comme aujourd'hui
actuellement il est pas majoritaire
et quand il est pas d'accord il fait
49.34 par exemple il rappelle tout le
monde à 3h du matin il refait voter tout
d'un bloc en en ayant rien à [ __ ] des
amendements et puis bah forcément il
était majoritaire ça passait pas vous
voulez quoi un grand soulèvement
populaire renverser les institutions le
peuple dans la rue on aurait aimé
l'éviter ça vraiment on aimerait que
vous pensez maintenant qu'on ne peut
plus l'éviter c'est parti en tout cas
mais parti pour un truc comme les gilets
jaunes on aurait pu discuter bien
longtemps avant que les premiers axes
passent ça pas été fait et on a attendu
moment on a attendu de savoir comment ça
allait se dérouler ce qui allait être
cassé etc avant de discuter donc à ce
moment là où il y a eu des discussions
sinon avant 10 milliards quand même
c'est pas c'est pas nul non on a obtenu
bien pour tous les citoyens justement
ça c'est intéressant je vous jette des
miettes et je vais vous dire bah soyez
satisfaite c'est un peu comme la fenêtre
d'overton vous connaissez la fenêtre
d'overton
c'est comment déplacer l'acceptable dans
un extrême ou l'autre
c'est pas ça c'est que si je vous dis
par exemple du jour au lendemain
on va passer le carburant à 2,50 vous
allez faire c'est fou puis vous allez
passer six mois à 2,50 et on va le
baisser à 2 euros vous allez faire ah
[ __ ] 2 € ça fait du bien il était à 10
au départ vous acceptez ce que vous
auriez jamais accepté parce qu'on joue
avec une fenêtre d'acceptabilité donc 10
milliards moi je veux bien Maxime c'est
comme les soldes c'est un peu ça
peut-être un centime sur le carburant si
je vous donne 10 milliards aujourd'hui
mais qu'en fait je vous laisse crever la
364 jours par an qu'est-ce que vous
voulez que ça me foute moi 10 milliards
est-ce que ça a changé à ma vie moi 10
milliards
Eric et Maxime et une aide que l'État a
donné 200 € parce que c'était parce que
le carburant a augmenté 100 euros divisé
par 12 mois sur une vie
Eric tu disais il y a un instant pêcher
de mourir on aimerait pas on n'a pas
envie d'arriver jusque là on aimerait
que ça soit évité est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
ce que vous dites là ce que vous nous
annoncez ce que ça peut être évité
qu'est-ce que vous aimeriez voilà vous
aimeriez parler à qui vous aimeriez que
ça se passe pour un toujours comme
exemple les pays où ça se passe moins
bien que dans le dos j'aimerais bien
qu'on prenne ce où ça se passe mieux que
dans le monde
cette phrase rien que cette phrase où
bien ça se passe mieux toujours prendre
pour exemple
pour dire bon on est pas trop mal
l'outil mais non c'est pas comme ça
qu'il faut voir la chance moi je préfère
qu'on regarde là où ça se passe bien
donc vous êtes en train de dire que
partout dans le monde ça se passe pas
mieux qu'en France et en France ça se
passe pas bien non je trouve que le
monde entier pas si mal que ça en France
il y a plein de trucs qui vont pas je
suis absolument d'accord avec vous
vraiment vous dire ça moi j'ai par
exemple quand on vous dites est-ce que
ça a été difficile de gilets jaunes moi
j'ai assisté des gens qui sont morts
d'un cancer par exemple et qu'on portait
le gilet jaune jusque lors d'un des
jours de vie et je lui fais un coucou à
Fabrice d'ailleurs qui est aujourd'hui
en Ukraine pour aider les gens par
exemple alors que il fait pas de
politique mais il aide les gens il a vu
son papa mourir avec un gilet jaune qui
avait pas les moyens de se soigner alors
je trouve qu'on est bien loti en France
oui c'est valable pour les gens qui se
sentent bien lotis
pour les gens qui se sentent pas bien
l'outils en France on est soigné quel
que soit ses moyens
c'est une question d'accès aux
médicaments tout le monde a accès aux
soins quand on a un cancer en France ah
oui oui bien sûr oui tout le monde a
accès aux soins quand on a un cancer en
France il y a plein de gens qui meurent
de cancer parce qu'ils peuvent pas être
pris en charge parce qu'il va pas assez
de médecin parce qu'il y a pas assez de
cancérologue parce qu'il y a des déserts
dans les déserts médicaux absolument
mais pas le faire
médicaux ça se passe pas bien enfin ça
n'existe pas quand vous avez un cancer
évidemment vous pouvez être soigner
puisque c'est marqué vous pouvez le
soigner mais quand le seul hôpital qui
peut vous soigner il a 250 km vous avez
un cancer votre mutuelle elle prend pas
en charge de taxi qu'il faut que vous
preniez toute votre famille pour aller
faire un rendez-vous qui sera dans 4
mois il y a des gens qui pour qui c'est
pas très simple de faire ça en fait mais
hériter donc c'est oui sur le papier en
théorie on est un pays qui fonctionne
très bien en théorie il y a des aides
sociales il y a l'assistance médicale
pour tout le monde il y a tout un tas de
choses merveilleuses mais dans la
pratique il y a longtemps que ça c'est
défaillant tout ça et il y a des gens
qui en pâtissent Eric et Maxime
aujourd'hui euh vous vous avez repris
j'ai envie de dire une activité normale
vous avez pu reprendre une activité
normale après tout ce qui s'est passé ou
bien vous avez perdu énormément d'argent
avec avec tout ce que on n'est pas comme
on parlait tout à l'heure on n'est pas
les plus à plaindre il y en a qui ont
été vraiment condamné fermement il y en
a qui ont été blessés mutilés
mais quand même vous est-ce que vous
vous avez
tout à l'heure mais on va pas on a eu
beaucoup
tué par une grenade au début de
l'interview c'est ça coûte cher des
gilets jaunes ça coûte très cher
comme plein de personnes on a eu
beaucoup de condamnations des amendes on
se trimballé sur Paris tous les 10
mètres on avait une amende parce qu'on
est en terrasse parce qu'on venait un
jour de manifestation on a eu des 135
euros d'amende considéré comme opposants
politiques radicalisés d'accord
on est dangereux très dangereux vous
arrivez vous vous travaillez normalement
maintenant vous Eric et vous Maxime ça
va ça se passe moi j'ai pas pu
travailler en France pendant plein
pendant un bon moment parce que quand un
patron recevait mon CV qui voyait mon
nom c'était on vous rappelle donc j'ai
bossé à Monaco un petit peu je t'ai
chauffeur de camion poubelle parce que
c'est un métier chauffeur et aujourd'hui
je travaille dans enfin je travaille je
suis dans la branche dans laquelle je
suis passionné d'accord tu nous donc
aéronautique
ma licence de pilote de brevet confirmé
enfin mon beau et puis notre confirmer
parapente je suis encore désespoir dans
la vie dans leur France maintenant qu'on
est pas mort il faut garder l'espoir
tu étais pas résigné tu te dis voilà tu
dis va avoir ça il va bah non moi je
suis plutôt déterminé c'est plus
dangereux sur le long terme parce qu'on
a l'impression qu'en mettant des amendes
en tapant dessus ils vont se calmer ils
vont rentrer chez eux mais du coup bah
on me disait on peut dire quand même
disait que ça se passait plutôt bien
avec la police à chaque fois que vous
avez été interpellé etc enfin entendu
mais c'est rien il y a beaucoup de
policiers aussi qui qui se disent gilets
jaunes
j'ai fait moi j'ai travaillé un an avec
eau de Lancelin où j'ai fait des
reportages j'ai interviewé un CRS j'ai
parlé avec beaucoup de policiers c'est
pareil dans les policiers comme dans la
société il y a il y a des bons et des
mauvais donc on est tombé sur des flics
et qui des officiers de police
judiciaires il y a des bons et des
mauvais mais c'est la société en fait
c'est pour ça gilets jaunes catégoriser
une une tranche de la population qui
n'arrive pas à joindre les deux bouts
c'est ça
je veux pas être antisémite raciste
homophobe sexiste casseurs je veux
surtout pas être gilet jaune mais en
fait est-ce que je suis contre
et là on contribue à ça donc en fait le
fait qu'il y a un mouvement a peut-être
tué le mouvement non non c'est les
médias c'est le mouvement comment on tue
au début il y avait un peu de
fascination on a été invité ici on a
toujours invité franchement Maxime éric
est la même même Jérôme qui m'appelle
que j'ai tout le temps
de nos yeux on a vu comment ça s'est
passé il y a eu de la fascination au
début puis après ça a été vraiment
d'essayer de casser en trouvant le
moindre défaut
alors franchement Maxime et Eric et même
tous les gens le disent sur les réseaux
je vois plein de gens qui disent
franchement Cyril il a jamais été j'ai
jamais été contre vous voilà et j'étais
tout voilà après ça a été les les les
machines
Éric et Maxime je suis obligé après de
mettre des gens aussi en face tu vois je
peux pas voilà on parlait des blocs tout
à l'heure là l'Arc de Triomphe qui a
fait un truc énorme quand il a été à
l'Arc de Triomphe je sais comment ça
s'est passé j'étais dedans où il y avait
les piles de pavés ils ont bloqué tous
les accès autour de lac de Triomphe nous
ont fait monter tranquillement les
Champs-Élysées jusqu'à nous laisser
Nasser toute l'après-midi là-dedans en
tirant des gaz lacrymogène c'est la
journée où il y a le plus de gaz
lacrymogène tiré dans la journée c'est
plus de 10000 cartouches je sais pas si
vous imaginez vous avez déjà respiré du
cm6s non ça fait pas du bien je vous le
dis surtout quand c'est toute
l'après-midi
nous on arrivait débuter du matin ça
gazait direct il y avait tout qui était
fait pour énerver les gens mais vraiment
parce qu'on pense que c'est les gilets
jaunes qu'on commence à attaquer les CRS
tout ça nous on l'avait vécu de 8h du
matin ou dès le matin ça commençait on
voulait pas que les gens soient là on
les éloignés de l'Arc de Triomphe on a
tout fait pour les énerver il y avait
des ça a commencé mais des vraiment de
18h du matin et après on rentre à la
maison et on passe pour des casseurs on
passe pour des gens qui ont attaquer les
CRS tout ça franchement ça fait mal
parce que toute la journée c'était très
compliqué merci
Eric il y a un truc très important sur
les dispositifs policiers aussi ça j'ai
fait un reportage là dessus je l'ai
filmé quand vous avez quand vous avez
des du public qui vous abordent de la
police ils ont un visage démasqué
visible un rio c'est le référentiel
d'identification obligatoire donc un
numéro d'identification qui permet à la
justice de pouvoir identifier un
policier qui aurait commis une bavure
par exemple ils sont très calmes avec de
l'armement léger en gilet correct une
petite gazeuse ils sont proches du
public ça c'est la première ligne la
deuxième ligne sont un peu plus masqué
en général on voit pas leur visage ils
ont toujours un petit Rio mais ils ont
un peu plus d'armement et là où nous on
était c'est de la braven là vous voyez
plus de visage vous voyez plus des Rio
et vous voyez que de la matraque du gaz
et des gens qui qui crient parce qu'ils
ont mal
et ça c'est loin des caméras loin du
public et loin de ce que retransmettait
BFM TV et ça si vous me croyez pas j'ai
des images des heures de vidéo de ça
mais des heures entières ou je discute
avec des policiers qui sont masqués et
des policiers qui ne le sont pas en leur
demandant pourquoi on voit pas votre RIO
un capitaine et un commandant qui me
répond à ah c'est dommage
faites attention parce que dans 5
minutes ça risque de dégager
à la base je voulais je voulais juste
venir ici dire ce que j'avais à dire et
quitter le plateau en disant de toute
façon c'est qu'un jeu ici ça ça sera pas
écouté et je suis plutôt agréablement
surpris parce qu'on a un temps de parole
qui est quand même assez impressionnant
ce soir
c'est compliqué
là franchement merci tu le sais et tu
sais qu'on a toujours vous allez c'est
toujours vous exprimer Éric aussi été un
des premiers à venir dis-moi ce que tu
as le message que j'ai à faire passer
aux gens c'est si vous vous arrêtez aux
étiquettes c'est vous qui allez y perdre
au final si vous voulez vraiment que les
choses changent il va falloir arrêter de
penser que on va pouvoir tomber d'accord
sur tout moi je peux pas être d'accord
sur certains sujets avec des gens c'est
pas pour autant que j'ai pas été dans la
rue avec eux pour lutter pour l'intérêt
collectif donc ce que tu es en train de
dire c'est que c'est ce que tu disais un
petit peu tout à l'heure quand vous
sortez dans la rue vous demandez pas
avec qui vous serez votre méthode
d'action que vous ne vouliez pas aller
dans la rue vous vouliez y aller
les méthodes d'action et c'est pas
simplement de la manifestation c'est le
fait de sortir le plus du système pour
ne pas y participer
moi je paye plus de loyer je paye plus
d’eau je paye plus d'électricité déjà je
suis autonome
donc c'est un mode de vie qui est
différent très bien mais j'ai
l'impression d'avoir un petit appart
j'ai pu me le permettre tout le monde ne
peut pas se le permettre mais il y a des
gens pour lutter bah ils vont aller
chercher les jeux à la ferme à 20 km
plutôt que d'aller nourrir un gros
groupe ou ce genre de choses chacun fait
comme il peut lutte comme il peut et
prépare l'après comme il peut mais
pensez plus à l'après qu'elle vous
battre avec des conneries maintenant
parce que vous allez payer plus tard